not allowing your brain to trick you
into that aloneness that fearful state
because we can go there in a second like
you could drive down the road and just
think of all the things that can kill
you while you're driving
and you could easily just terrify
yourself like your brain is so
powerful but i really feel like your
mouth is even more powerful so speak
life over your situation you don't want
to have to be humbled but
i again i always look back at the things
that were most transforming in my life
and it was always those hard times
that really i go wow i wish i didn't
experience that
but having experienced that has
completely changed
the way i live now and for the better
that was alexa penavega and we just had
the most amazing conversation together i
cannot wait for you to listen to it
we talk all about birth all of our birth
experiences and most specifically her
most recent birth with her daughter rio
we talk about when life happens
unexpectedly
and the tools and the mindset to have so
that you can be best prepared for when
things don't always go to plan and i
really hope that you find this episode
encouraging and possibly even healing
i share found a lot of joy through this
conversation and a lot of great value
from it so without further ado
let's get into this episode
all right welcome to the ellen fisher
podcast today i'm going to be speaking
to alexa penavega
alexa is an actress you probably know
her from spy kids
as the character carmen cortez i know i
loved that movie as a kid
and now my kids love that movie too
alexa played in various roles in her
young and adult life she even competed
on dancing with the stars alongside her
husband carlos penavega
and together they recently had their
third child and are raising their family
on the island here together
we connected through a mutual friend and
started following each other on
instagram
and she is a passionate mother of three
and source for positivity so today i
wanted to have her
here on the podcast to talk about her
latest birth with her third child
rio thank you so much alexa for coming
on the show today
no thank you so much for having me it's
funny because i was talking to lois
about doing this
he's like babe do you remember we used
to watch so many of her videos on
youtube
and i totally forgot that we had but we
used to watch
so many of your videos oh my gosh i had
no idea well i didn't either
he reminded me that was ellen oh
i know i had no idea that is so cool
it's awesome but so you've been helping
our family longer than you even know
wow oh my gosh that is so good i did not
know that and it's great that we just
figured this out on the podcast together
it only took i don't know years i guess
yes
now the reason i want to talk to you
today was because i found the way that
you shared about your
recent birth online so openly and
vulnerably to be
an incredible powerful one and i think
so many women
struggle with healing from birth or
traumas if they didn't get the birth
that they had planned or envisioned
especially because as women we only get
to experience this like super sacred
transformative experience yeah a handful
of times at the most
so if we don't get the birth that we're
planning for and really or really
excited for
often i think that like resentment or
hurt can set in and
really take time to heal so i just hope
today we can like
hear your story and for it to be
hopefully a source of encouragement
and even maybe a place for healing for
some people i love that
awesome awesome awesome okay do you want
me to get into it yes
yeah my first question is i noticed that
this was the first birth where you
planned or desired to have a home birth
so what made you
want to have a home birth this time
around um so actually i wanted a home
birth with all three kids
ocean i was my heart has always desired
giving birth at home
um i can't tell you why it just seemed
most natural
being able to you know bring your child
in
uh like bring your child to this earth
right at your home being able to go like
right to your bed afterwards
but that was terrifying for my husband
and i definitely didn't want to do
something that he
wasn't comfortable with i wanted us to
both be on the same page and if that
meant
that i wasn't having a home birth that
was fine with me
because i i didn't want to do something
he was uncomfortable with
so we had ocean it was a fantastic birth
um i and that was in california i had
kingston here in hawaii
um that was a great birth as well also
in the hospital
but this time around things were a
little different this is number three
and carlos was like babe let's do it
let's have a home birth and i was in
shock because i didn't even ask him this
time i assumed that
it was all still the same and he just
kept meeting women like you
meeting other women on the island who
just had fantastic
home birth experiences right the fear
for him
was gone and he was fully ready he's
like let's do this
if i have to i'll catch the baby
so he was fully in this time around wow
that's amazing i think it's really cool
how important it is to be on the same
page it is ultimately
super important for both of both people
to feel
safe in the birth experience 100 and you
don't want to feel alone you don't want
to feel like i'm forcing my husband into
this so yeah
for us it made the most sense that we're
on the same page
totally so can you tell us what happened
this time around give us the story i
don't
even know the full story and i'm so
excited i will give you the scoop
so um again planning a home birth we
were gonna have it
we were like please may i may i start
laboring and have this baby at sunset
like you know
you you envision the ideal situation
right
um but my around like 5 a.m
um a week before rio was born my bag of
water started leaking
how many weeks were you i was only 33
weeks
wait yeah 34. 34 weeks wow um
oh no 33 weeks you guys i can't think
right now i'm still mom brain this is
how it is a new one i don't have a
newborn
all i know is she was a little she was
six weeks and two days early so whatever
that makes me
okay um so i i
i feel this dripping and at first i
think i have peed myself because i'm
feeling very large
this time and i'm like okay i'm just
gonna go to the bathroom and i
immediately pee so
i brush it off and i'm thinking oh my
gosh i just wet the bed i've never done
that before and i tell carlos i'm like
laughing
like babe i think i just beat it because
it's not on your radar that you're about
to have your
ocean was two weeks late and kingston
was right on his due date
and but i happened to um be in a very
stressful situation i was at a funeral
the day that i went into labor with
kingston so i assumed that the stressful
situation
was kind of what um put me into labor
so i assumed that kingston would have
been late as well so this time around
i'm not thinking rio is gonna be like
born anytime soon
um i go back to bed and i wake up and
the same thing happens and this time
when i go to the bathroom
it's light pink and i'm going okay but
i'm not i'm not worried at all i i
totally am just like let's just go see
what happens
i go visit my midwife she says that i
need to go to the hospital
so i i go to the hospital and they
i don't know if you guys know this but
on maui we do not have a nicu
that is on oahu right so they
immediately
medivac me out to oahu and did you know
this at the time that they didn't have a
nicu hair
i you so so my midwife did inform me
saying like they don't have a nicu and
they'll probably send you to wahoo
but i'm a very optimistic person i'm
like no my bag of waters is gonna seal
i'm gonna have this baby here merrily
you're still gonna deliver it
and everything's gonna be good they're
not shipping me to oahu and i went in
and immediately they're like we're gonna
send you to a while
wow my husband's in the parking lot with
my kids and
i'm not prepared at all we were running
errands before
this moment like let's just stop at the
hospital on the way over honestly that's
i'm not even joking that's exactly what
happened so i have nothing
all i have is my phone which is like the
battery's almost dead anyway
so i'm texting carlos just saying hey um
they are sending me out i don't know
what to do so he had somebody
come watch the kids real fast and he
gives me a phone charger and he's like
when you go into labor call me um and
that was three days later
wow so when did he get to ohio so he
didn't get there until 30 minutes before
i delivered
are you serious yeah yeah so well
because we have two boys
and we could have left them with someone
else but they were already freaking out
that i just disappeared i didn't give
them any warning i just took off
and i didn't think about how stressful
it would have been on them
yeah so like on facetime i'm just kind
of trying to talk them through it
because they had been prepping for a
home birth
i've been showing them so many um like
little
home birthing videos just to get them
comfortable with the idea so
now they're going oh mommy's giving
birth to rio
at the hospital and carlos is trying to
explain to them yes sometimes things
change and that's okay
so i get to oahu they could not have
been nicer it was absolutely amazing
the doctors just made me feel so
comfortable with everything that was
happening
um and then so three days later i'm
finally into labor
and carlos is getting somebody to watch
the kids and booking flights
we um lose her heartbeat
and i'm only four centimeters dilated
and at this point i've felt
so much peace the entire time like i'm
telling you
from the moment i was like from the
moment i thought
uh or from here let me really retract
that from the moment my bag of waters
started leaking until i had her i had
complete peace there was never a moment
that entered my mind
that uh something bad was gonna happen
or that i needed to be fearful
because in my head i've always looked at
these situations like it is written
like there is already a path for me
there is already something written out
for rio
so i have to completely have faith that
she is going to be
fine and that i'm gonna be fine and if
things don't work out the way i want
them to
that's okay because this is a written
path that
is already like predestined like i can i
couldn't change it if i wanted to
um wow so so i think that gave me a lot
of peace
but then they lose her heartbeat and i'm
starting to go okay i'm still gonna be
happy
and i'm gonna still like you know have
faith that everything's gonna be fine
but i'm
kind of starting to go all right are you
guys gonna give me an emergency
c-section
what's happening i'm like shaking my
belly trying to kind of move her around
and the doctor walks in randomly and and
sees what's happening and they go okay
we're going to flip you over we're going
to move you around to try to get our
heart beat back
because a minute's a long time to lose
your kid's heartbeat the nurse
lifts the uh covers and just starts
screaming
because rio had already come out
so rio her full head was out i barely
pushed at all and the rest of her body
came
out and it was insane i mean that is a
crazy story it was absolutely insane so
yes i had an epidural because i totally
would have felt her come
out but i ended up getting an infection
in the hospital and i was hoping that
the epidural would help
because it was so unbelievably painful
and
um i thought it would help but did you
know infections cover themselves
from from the epidural so you can still
feel the infection
but the epidural numbs everything out
everything else except the infection yes
and you did not know that you know i did
not know that going in i thought that
would
that would cure the infection issue
little did you know
nope had no idea that is a crazy story
yeah so i went from
going like i went from walking into the
situation saying i want this all natural
home birth
to doing literally the exact opposite
but i couldn't be happier with the
outcome
that is amazing yeah that is so
inspiring your mindset
is truly so powerful because i
personally have not gone through an
experience like that and
i really don't know if i would be that
positive and yeah i i think that that is
like
amazing i would have said the same thing
not that i'm not a fearful person i'm a
really happy person
and i always try to look at the positive
because i know like
you know that i'm a very faith-filled
person and i just know like
god has me but that doesn't always mean
that it's going to be butterflies and
rainbows i've gone through a ton of
difficult stuff but now i look back and
i'm like
wow thank god i went through that stuff
because it was so
instrumental at that time in my life
where it really pivoted me
in one direction when i could have gone
another um so i always take those as
wins even though they feel like losses
they're wins for your life and you have
no idea why
and you have no idea how they're going
to affect other people and and i think
that's like i have to look at the bigger
picture it's so easy for us to be
me focused or um this isn't necessarily
what
i wanted and and it's really frustrating
that it's not working out
but you have no idea how it's affecting
those around you like
everything you everything you do has
a reaction um i don't know if i'm
explaining this right absolutely aren't
i'm like i'm fully understanding what
you're saying because there's times like
pretty much almost every time i'm going
through something that feels incredibly
hard in the moment it's really hard to
accept the reality and to know that like
everything works out in the end
yes you know and that in the end or just
later you're going to look back at that
time be like oh
that happened and as a result this
happened maybe it wouldn't have happened
if that didn't happen 100 percent
there's a hundred percent so many times
where like literally every time i've
gone through something that's hard
in the end i'm like i i needed to go
through that yes
it becomes your testimony and i love
that and i feel like
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter what your beliefs are i think
everybody has testimonies to pull from
totally and i think that is an amazing
way to look at life
it's harder to do it's easier said than
done for sure in the moment
when you're in it it sucks let's be real
like when you're in it
so how do you do it then when you're in
it how do you stay positive and where do
you get that source of positivity this
honestly it felt like this particular
situation almost felt supernatural
because i had so much
peace and i think a lot of that had came
from
um practice in a weird way i've had
plenty of times in my life that have
been very very frustrating some that
people have known about some that are
you know
still private and personal but when you
go through those
moments whether they're small things or
big things that's your time to practice
choosing joy even when it's not hard i
mean even when it's not easy even when
it's really really hard
um and the more and more you choose joy
in those little moments like
i can't tell you like when my kid throws
a tantrum it's so
frustrating but i can either sit there
and be stressed out by it or i can start
laughing and be like
oh buddy like my heart feels for you
because you can't figure out your
emotions right now
so that's me going i'm gonna choose joy
and i'm gonna love him and then
i'm gonna nurture him to try to figure
out how to get through this tantrum and
at the same time
i'm nurturing my heart without even
realizing it instead of stressing my
heart out i'm nurturing my heart so
the more and more you do that in the
smaller situations when something big
comes up
like um whether it's you know not the
birth plan you want
or whether it's losing a child losing a
pregnancy whatever it may be
your heart will be more prepared for
those big moments but it takes the
exercise beforehand
you don't want to make me cry because
you don't go into a marathon having
never practiced
and and i'm not saying that you can't do
that you can still choose joy
even if you've never practiced choosing
it but
it really does make a difference if you
can start that now so
if there's somebody out there that
really needs this you should start that
now because
i guarantee you there's gonna always be
a point in our lives where we are
tested far be far greater than we've
ever been tested before
and you're gonna look back and go oh
thank god i chose joy in those little
moments because it's really getting me
through this time right now and it
completely changes your experience
yes because two people can have the same
exact experience
but then when they can be miserable and
one have a totally
miserable experience and the other has a
completely different outlook on how that
same exact experience happens yes and so
i found the most helpful when i'm in
those moments like parenting
or in those harder moments to like i
want to just
like lash out or get upset or just be
like life is terrible right now instead
though like if i just pause
instead of like just trying to have a
reaction right away but i pause
for like a minute walk away for a minute
and then just like collect myself and
realize like
i am safe life is good yep you go back
into it and have a completely different
outlook you're prepared
yes and the laughing really does help
it makes a huge difference although i
will say it drives my husband nuts
because if we're in an argument
first off it makes me want to laugh now
which is not necessarily
he's like why are you laughing why are
you laughing at me this is not funny but
he also knows that this is my process
which is good because we never get into
yelling arguments or anything like that
i'm not a yelly person i never have been
um so whenever we get into a
disagreement or an argument
we handle it really well it drives him
nuts though because he can't like we're
both
very hispanic so yeah you know very
passionate about the things that we
believe in
um but it's calmed him down a lot
from like the beginning of our
relationship he would get riled up and
i'm just like i don't do that so
you're not going to be like honestly it
does make it easier because whoever
you're around if they're staying calm
and collected you're going to have a
much easier time staying common
collection 100
and if someone in this thing goes for
like parenting your kids like sense your
stress
completely so you're stressed out
they're getting stressed out fully my
kid the other day randomly
he had no idea that i was just kind of
like frustrated with some things
and he just came over he's like mom do
you need a hug i was like
yes i do yeah thank you and it makes it
so much better
always that they care about you yeah and
they're so in tune
they're so cartoon they really are so
tell me what happened like after you
gave birth like the rest of your nicu
experience so the rest
of my nicu experience was fantastic um
they we thought we were gonna be there
around six weeks and we were only there
for one week
wow yeah rio was a awesome fighter it
was incredible
but my heart was prepared to be there
longer if i needed to be and i think
that's the big thing we could have
tried to be like no we want her out
sooner but my goal was not to get her
out there as
fast as possible that would be nice but
my goal was let's hit
those um those marks like they have
these
these milestone marks that they put for
you in the hospital like okay let's make
sure she's gaining weight that's a
milestone
let's make sure that she can be um in a
bed by herself not in an incubator so
like making sure that she can keep her
body temperature
luckily she was not jaundice so she
didn't have to go under a light but like
so many little things and when you see
your kid
hooked up to all these
random things like going from okay
natural home birth to
my kid has 30 wires coming out of their
body
and they're super small like smaller
than you would have ever expected
and you're trying to hold them and
breastfeed it can be
really overwhelming and you haven't
slept so let's like
let's put all these things there but all
i was thinking was she's here
and she's alive and like i have her and
i'm gonna take that
that's my win i'm gonna take this win
right now and
for the moments that i had carlos with
me i'm like you know what i have my
partner with me he's my teammate
that's a win you just you find every
little moment that
and make those your wins instead of
going my kid has
you know 10 wires or 15 wires or 30
wires or my kid only weighs this much or
they're not gaining weight they're
losing weight like
if we focus on those like we're totally
going to become
fearful and i really feel like her
healing
would not have been the same because i
really believe babies are so in tune
so i was holding her like crazy it's
just doing as much skin-to-skin as
possible
um feeding her as often as they would
allow me to feed her
yeah um and i i really feel like just
that
positivity and staying joyful in those
moments with her
kind of gave her the strength that she
needed
that is so beautiful and amazing and i
really
totally agree i wholeheartedly agree
with that they are completely aware
and they feel what you're feeling yeah
and if you were focusing on all the
negative aspects like i didn't get the
birth i wanted like
and the amount of wires and all that or
the weight gain and stuff like that then
you wouldn't be seeing like the joy
and the goodness that happened out of
that experience you wouldn't
so i do have to say this though so my
husband he
he left after um two days of being with
me
to go back to the boys because they were
really hurting so they needed daddy
um and the first time that i was alone
by myself like she's in the incubator
and i'm finally alone by myself
it was i finally just kind of bawled i
just let it all out but it wasn't this
i'm sad cry it wasn't like it was a
relief
yeah it was like this relief and release
all at the same time of like whoa
we did that like yeah she's here i can
breathe
um like it was just the sense of
like all the stuff that could have been
overwhelming that i
we like did not allow ourselves to get
overwhelmed but we were able to just
take all the stuff that would have
overwhelmed us and just push it out
and that that moment for me was super
important because i know that a lot of
times in my past
i would have remained joyful but i
wouldn't have found a release for
you know maybe some of the harder stuff
i wouldn't have been able
to just cry it out because i felt like
oh if i cry does that mean
i'm failing like no is it crying doesn't
mean failure crying doesn't even mean
sad crying crying can be just the
perfect release that you need so
yeah definitely had a good cry for sure
because if you're holding it all in that
like harbors over time
for sure you really need to release it
100 whether that's with someone you love
or needing to do that by yourself yeah
like and that might even
take more than one time yeah like
depending on who you are your
experiences what you experience
totally totally i think being alone made
me more aware of it though
because with carlos i had my partner
right and then when he leaves you're
finally alone to kind of think about
everything that happened and again i
never got sad
i never felt like um i didn't get the
experience that i wanted
like i never had those hurt or
upset feelings i just had wow we made it
yeah
and i think i think that was like the
healthiest response i could have had
absolutely it is because i actually have
two people that i've known on the island
who had to be airlifted to oahu they
were in labor ended up needing a
c-section or they were thinking the baby
would
need to be brought to nicu so they
airlifted her
the two women that i know separate
occasions obviously and the
partner and child had to stay behind and
they didn't let the partner come on the
plane with them even though they were
like in the middle of labor yeah
and i remember hearing those stories and
feeling so like robbed for them
like that feels so unfair like yeah and
actually
there was there was one of them where
the baby was born and then needed to be
airlifted so they took the baby and left
the mom
the mom wasn't able to guard the baby so
hard and i really feel like there's some
something needs to change there to wear
like a priority of having the mother
be on that airlifting so that she can be
there because that is so important
so the nicu people will even tell you
and it's really frustrating because the
the nicu is so separate from what goes
on with just like the birthing nurses
what goes on prior to even getting to
oahu
i don't know how it would be you know on
the mainland i think usually they have
access yeah much easier access but still
um
in the nicu they say the best thing for
the babies is the mother holding the
babies as much as possible
they say that like the the kids that
have to be in the nicu get out of there
so much faster yes when the parents are
there
holding the babies and like yes and
breastfeeding the baby and breastfeeding
the babies like
all four yeah they call it the kangaroo
time the more kangaroo time you can have
with your baby
and um you know i get it like i
didn't even sleep that week i was
because every two hours you're feeding
your baby it's on like a very strict
schedule and they're happy to do it for
you but i'm like no i
like i need this time with her and i
want her to heal they tell you how
important that is the problem is
the nicu is so separate from the rest of
the world right
so when you have these people airlifting
a baby out of there
i'm sure like there's all sorts of
insurance purposes and
whatnot but but it needs to change
because if we're seeing the effects
of a mother and a baby and a baby
healing much faster because it's
close to its mother why on earth would
we separate them
it makes no sense and not only that the
importance of like post-traumatic stress
and post-prime depression rates when
you're separated from your baby
for the mother it's so important it's so
important and i think
honestly i believe that that was a lot
of the reason why carlos wanted to do
a home birth this time around just
because we are in a very different
season
with like the way the world is right now
and he was seeing so many moms
getting their babies taken away from
them because of like
like whatever restrictions the hospital
had because of the time that we're in
yeah
and and he was like i don't want that to
happen to you yeah i don't want to not
be able to see my kid
he's like absolutely not like let's do
the home birth and that's what got him
gung-ho about the home birth
and you know now we talk about other
babies and he's like listen it's okay
ria wasn't supposed to be born
at home yeah the next one i think oh
good you want more yeah
and you know there's so many women
though who have had amazing hospital
experiences like you even yourself when
you're there you had an amazing
incredible amazing nurses and that's
like not to discount that at all like
i'm speaking on like the the
people that i know who experienced being
separated from the baby
from their partner and just how much we
need to change that yeah
the health of both brothers i guarantee
you if you were to really ask the people
who are having to do the separating
i would say nine times out of ten or
like more like
almost 10 out of 10 times yeah they
wouldn't want to separate it either
it's just like the rules that they have
to implement and
and i i can't tell you how many amazing
doctors i met there
and i don't know why i think i felt like
i was expecting all of them to kind of
frown upon me because i'm walking in
having like no preparation because i'm
prepared for a home birth so they know
like oh you're not getting your home
birth like all i was thinking was do
they think i'm judging them because
they're doctors you're in a hospital
and there wasn't any of that they were
just
the most that's fabulous yeah they were
fantastic that's amazing i actually
um had with my third pregnancy
i went and got an ultrasound i got an
ultrasound for each of my homeworks just
one of them but
um three of the kids the first two in
the last it was like a separate
like um just place where you get an
ultrasound that wasn't at the hospital
but the third one i decided to go into
kaiser because i had kaiser at the time
and i'm like i'm just going to get like
like in their system because they
appreciate if you're like in your system
and if you did have to be transferred
they already know your information right
yeah so i went there
but i had decided to do that at like 30
something weeks pregnant and so they
were like
wait this is your first wait huh i know
i know this is your first time here what
why are you coming right now
what's going on so then i said like oh
i'm having a home birth it's gonna be my
third home birth
and i definitely felt like the sense
from the nurses that i experienced to be
kind of like frowning upon that right
yeah and then
uh but and so i was like whatever you
know it's okay like i i'm very confident
in my choice and i'm like happy to like
come there and get that stuff for them
so that they
have that on file if i didn't need to be
transferred and then at one point after
the nurses were done
um the doctor came in and he was like
hey
so just let you know we have to tell you
that we don't recommend homeburst
here's a paper yeah you know he's like
but he was like but
this is like your third time you're
probably going to be fine yeah and he
was like really sweet about it yeah
i was surprised by that because i had
kind of i guess i had these
subconscious thoughts that maybe it
wouldn't go isn't it funny that we think
that like
yeah and sure there are some people that
are just like you're insane why are you
having a home birth you have hospitals
now so much can go wrong in home birth
yeah
but if you're literally trained
to think that way your entire schooling
and then you're in a hospital where you
know yes you do
often see like some really bad you can
see how bad home birth experiences
where people are rushed to the hospital
and then they do clean up messes
absolutely and yeah but that's what
they're there for i'm not trying to be
mean like
but for instance i always tell people i
try to do things as naturally as
possible
but if i get into a car accident i'm not
going to go home and eat broccoli i'm
going to go to the hospital
and there's a time and place for modern
medicine for sure totally thankful for
it yes actually for real
real experience is a prime example it
was fantastic
but i would do we have time for me to
tell a quick story absolutely okay
so um when i when we decided to do
a home birth i was i think 26 weeks
pregnant or 27 weeks somewhere around
there i was already yeah i was already
far enough along um but i'm really bad
about going to doctors visits anyway
so i had only gone in a couple times
right um
but i was terrified to tell these girls
hey
i've decided that we're going to do a
home birth especially this
late in the game yeah um i didn't want
to be
uh disrespectful to them and i really
care about them
they're fantastic women like it's a
group of like i think five women
in this practice and they're wonderful
so i went in there and i was just
straight up
i was like i just told them look my
husband's finally excited about doing a
home birth i've been wanting this since
the first birth there's nothing wrong
with you guys like you guys are
fantastic
but this has been a desire on my heart
and i'm like waiting for them to just
not that they're mean people because i
love them but i'm just like waiting for
that judgment yeah right
um and they could not have been kinder
that's so just so lovely and just saying
like
obviously we recommend a home birth and
them actually saying we really wish
there were birthing centers on island
because that's something that they have
like even fought for themselves
which might be in the works actually in
the future yes i have i know i've been
following along really really hoping
that that happens
that would be amazing one day but i've
heard like the re like between money and
politics and all this
stuff like it just hasn't happened yet
but it was awesome
to be able to have that conversation and
i know i was prepared for it to go
either way
yeah um but because i was honest and
this is super important for you guys to
hear if
you're choosing home birth after um
going to like like some regular doctor
for your birthing experience
um because i was honest they were like
at any point
if you change your mind even up to
you're at home and you're getting ready
to like give birth to this baby
and you decide i need to go to the
hospital call us
and we'll still be there for you it
wasn't this well you chose home birth
we're out of here like good luck and it
was just still we want to be here for
you because you were straight up
with us yeah and you respected us enough
to give us the
like that's absolute truth that's
wonderful and i do think that certain
areas have um a different kind of
culture about it and like it has changed
a lot over the years yeah like when our
parents were giving birth
totally yeah and so i think over time it
is gonna get more and more connected to
like kind of working together that is
like that would be i think the most
ideal
it was even even the doctor when he told
me like you're probably going to be fine
when i got that ultrasound he went on to
say like you know
we realize or i realize that like we
only see the worst of the worst we don't
see
like the wonderful 9 out of 10
experiences that are wonderful at home
you know your midwife's not going to
call me and be like the baby's great
everything's fine
i'm only seeing the like one out of 10
times when someone's coming in and
needing our services so like i realized
that
and you know that's awesome well i was
like so amazed by that i always tell
people i'm like here's the truth
anybody can deliver a baby but what
these doctors train for
is it's the trauma um they they're able
to see things that
we can't see so if you're looking for a
midwife too i always tell people like
make sure that
they ask them how many babies they've
delivered and ask them about the hard
times about the times where
it didn't go right because this is also
going to prepare your heart it's going
to prepare you to make
a decision on like who you pick because
it's i feel like that's such a big deal
and that was something that i didn't
um i didn't know enough about going
into like home birthing situations was
like i'm like oh well my husband could
just
deliver it if we have to but if
something goes wrong
you want to have somebody there yeah you
want an expert there exactly
so i remember talking to the girls at
uh at i don't know if like i can say
their names or whatever but like the
mauilani
place i was telling them like yes the
person i found i feel like she's well
equipped she's like delivered
so many babies i'm like she's old not in
a bad way merrily you're old in a good
way you're old and wise
but she's older and she's been doing
this for a long time so i felt
so confident felt safe yeah that's
wonderful actually two of my
bursts was from a midwife like um my
second and third child was from a
midwife who
was like super well reputed and had been
giving birth to babies on the island for
decades she even
was like helping women give birth in
somalia at some point had some amazing
stories there oh my gosh she was just
amazing and then she retired after scout
was
born it was like it was like one of her
last bursts i believe
and she was amazing all of my midwife
experiences were amazing
but let's also talk about um like women
who plan for hospital births and it
doesn't go
the way that they plan they end up
having babies at home right some of that
there's that or there's also the aspect
of like hoping that you know maybe
nurses are a doctor or just like that
your story will go differently and you
end up
having different kinds of experiences
okay so here i'll even say this
i had my first my first week at the
hospital was fantastic and everybody was
incredible
my last two days that i was in the nicu
they they switched doctors and they
switched nurses
um not that they were mean or
bad they were not as friendly and as
like vivid personnel like they didn't
have these bright personalities
that the first round had yeah um
and had i probably had them the first
week it would have made my time a lot
harder
um would i have still been fine 100
would i have still fought through it 100
um and i know that you know
sometimes people will get that on their
first week or their second week
or their whole stay like you just don't
know what kind of personalities you're
gonna
um come up against but that's why like i
always tell people you cannot let your
circumstance
dictate your happiness because the
second your circumstance
controls how you like like your emotions
how you feel
like then you're out of control um
i say that though with a grain of salt
because are we ever really in control
totally so i say come up with a birth
plan that's awesome
nine times out of ten something is not
going to go the way that you wanted it
to
just because that's how life is where we
can only control so much
and i think our emotions are something
that we really can control even though
they feel out of control
yes we have to constantly it goes back
to choosing joy choosing happiness
and i think that's where the daily
practice comes in because it makes it
easier when you do have the really hard
totally
totally uh yeah i mean there's so much
to be said about that i think
i want to know too like what advice you
have for women who experience heartache
from birth and are struggling to heal
um oh man i think the big thing
is you're not in a race to heal quickly
like you don't have to you don't have to
just suck it up to suck it up
for other people around you like
obviously if you have other kids and
something has gone wrong whether you've
lost a baby or something
it's okay to let dad take the reins for
a little bit so that you can heal
and also be honest with your kids too
because we forget that
kids are going through stuff as much as
we are and we don't
we don't know how things are affecting
them like for instance my birth with rio
i had no idea that that was affecting my
kids
until i got back and like they just both
started bawling they met her and they
were like i'm so glad she's okay
and i'm thinking oh my gosh you can
understand this i can't believe you
understand this
right um so i feel like allowing
yourself
that that time to either grieve or go
through the process but also
focusing on the wins that you have had
like focusing if you had
if you had a um i'm trying to figure out
because i feel like every scenario
is different when it comes to focusing
on your wins but
but again it's just that goes back to
choosing choosing joy and for me
knowing everything is already written
like it
is written i always go back and you know
you know i'm like very faith-filled so
scripture has really helped me through
things
knowing that i'm not alone like i can
pray and talk to god
even when it feels like i'm completely
alone and i feel like
like faith for people is super super
important in
difficult times and not allowing your
brain
to trick you into that aloneness
that fearful state because we can go
there in a second like
you could drive down the road and just
think of all the things that can kill
you while you're driving
and you could easily just terrify
yourself like your brain is so
powerful but i really feel like your
mouth is even more powerful so
speak life over your situation um
the one thing i tell people is like i
believe that god made this earth
and if you like if you read the
scripture it literally says like
god spoke it all into existence so for
me i think like there's so much
power in our tongues and the things that
we say about ourselves or the things
that we say about situations
so regardless if you believe in the
bible or you don't
i feel like speak life into your
situation
make sure that you're constantly saying
positive things even if the situation is
dreadful
and it just seems like there's no way
out of this there's no good outcome
don't speak that speak life and just
keep saying it right
and if you do need a time just like
obviously to mourn like like for you
like the crying
yeah some people real i mean for me i
need to talk out what i'm feeling
when i'm like going through something
and everyone's going to be different
yeah everybody's going through something
i'm going to be like i need to just say
all the feelings that i have right now
and just get it all out get it all out
and then i can move forward
more quickly and also i think that's my
husband yeah but he's like
gets so annoyed with me because i'm like
well babe but this and they just stop
yeah
just let me say all the things that i
want to say i don't i don't want to be
positive right now i'm like
that's okay that you don't want to be
positive but i'm going to be positive
for you
for you yeah andrew my husband is the
same way like similar
to you and that he's just like look at
the right side everything's great and
i'm like
i don't want to bring your neck right
now i'm like such a i am actually a
super positive person but when i'm
really going through something i want
i want like that my person to just
relate to me yeah and you know he's very
much like but like
life is good babe and i'm like stop
talking
right and also though i think something
really important for women going
through or just healing from a traumatic
birth experience or trauma
through whatever they went through for
their birth or pregnancy is to realize
that like like you said you're not alone
and i think one of the reasons that it's
so so it can be difficult
is because that experience is so sacred
and heart opening that you're so
vulnerable
to other people even around you so like
you said like maybe in a normal
circumstance when you're like at the
grocery store and like if you have like
a grumpy cashier it's not going to
affect your day no you know
versus like a super positive cashier it
really is not going to change that much
it might be you might be like wow that
positive cashier just like really made
my day yeah
but like the grumpy one isn't
necessarily no like
what's wrong with them but then you move
on you move on but like when you're
experiencing such a
heart opening experience it is it's very
it can be devastable it can be very
impactful even just like the slightest
difference in who's in the room with you
through what you're experiencing because
like the way that you go through birth
sometimes you just want to be completely
alone
or you only you definitely want like
your people who support you so if you're
not feeling that support
you feel it 10 times over well i also
sorry this just reminded me of something
um so when i was uh
not quite in labor yet with rio i had a
few different nurses
um just because i was there for a while
beforehand and
um before i think the day before i
didn't know like you just don't know
when you're gonna go into labor
um i had a nurse say hey uh you can
request whoever
you want and i can always put it on
there just in case
and i was so thankful that she said that
because i was able to request her again
because i kept telling her i'm like i
don't want to lose you
like the girl i had yesterday was
awesome she was nice but she's not you
you know yeah and and i was able to
request her
so that whenever she was on she was in
my section so
don't be afraid to like ask people yes
um to like to be able to put in requests
or to be able to ask
like if you if you're uncomfortable and
you want more more covers or if you want
another pillow or
if you like don't be afraid to use your
voice the worst thing that they're gonna
say is no
um so like even i was just like do you
guys have i remember when i was giving
birth to ocean but i had an epidural
and they wouldn't let me eat anything
but they happened to have
um it wasn't shave ice but it was um
like sorbet yeah they would let me eat
sorbet instead of just ice chips
so i was like oh this is fantastic so
i'm sitting there i'm like do you guys
have sorbet and they're like no we don't
that would be amazing though like oh man
um okay so it's like rounding out that
specific conversation because we kind of
covered a lot about like
traumas from birth and i think for women
who
are maybe pregnant and they're like how
do i make sure i'm going into it
as um well-equipped as possible so that
if things do go awry
like how do i handle it like you've
totally covered that i think you covered
it amazing
and then for the women who have already
experienced
like the trauma i think like like we
said
the letting yourself feel it and having
yourself like letting yourself release
it and mourn it
and speak to whoever is the person that
you can speak to
and then also realizing your blessings
and realizing you're not alone i think
that is like
the one of the most impactful ways that
we can realize that like you're not the
only one who's felt this there are so
many women who have
gone through this before you and are
experiencing it right now
and like your feelings are valid and
safe yeah
and like you can accept it while still
moving forward from it yes
absolutely i mean and another thing i
really feel like it helps to share
with people um not like whether it's
just on a friendship level
like just with your friends or i mean
like nowadays with social media we can
share everything with everyone right
um but i've noticed that it makes such a
difference when i'm shared with people
because i'm able to continue to release
when i do that
um but i don't know who it's impacting
by telling my story and oftentimes
you'll hear people say like oh well i'm
just
i'm just me like i just i'm just you
know a cashier
i'm just this or i'm just that and it
drives me nuts when people say i'm just
because you're not just anything you're
you
and you have an impact everywhere you go
whether you're a cashier whether you're
the rock like i don't care who you are
you have an impact on people because
you can be again joyful or that grumpy
person but you're to have an impact
whether you're the joyful person or the
grumpy person
so i always feel like it's super awesome
when
i see because i'm that weird like
i probably would be a stalker if i
wasn't an actor
i love seeing what um people are doing
on instagram
that like i don't even know i'll like
search random things and like find
joe schmoe with like 200 followers and
i'm so curious to like what they're
doing in their lives
and it's awesome when you see these
people really
share their lives and be so vulnerable
out there i'm like oh my gosh
this person with 200 followers just made
a huge impact in my life so i always
tell people i'm like
we're so focused on followers and so
focused on like
who's watching my social media and all
this stuff you have no idea who you're
impacting by telling your story so just
tell it and it's so healing for you
for you too so i'm like just tell your
story please yes
that's so beautiful and so helpful okay
i also want to get into
about how your pregnancy went because i
saw you did a post about how there were
two sides to pregnancy
yeah tell me about how it went for you
pregnancy okay my first two pregnancies
were
wonderful i just felt huge the whole
time because i had very big boys but
other than that like
just really positive pregnancies this
pregnancy was really hard for me
um it was a lot more aches and pains
um when i was talking to the doctor she
was laughing because she was telling me
well you're older now you're older than
you were with the last two pregnancies
i'm like oh yeah that's true
and then you're also chasing two kids so
so not to be negative nancy after i've
talked about
being joyful but i'm just gonna be very
honest this was just really hard
and and i did feel like man
i wish that this were an easier
pregnancy but again i would take my wins
i was still able to move around
i wasn't um i didn't i wasn't bedridden
i was able to just kind of do the things
that i was doing
um the most frustrating part was
probably
probably the varicose veins that i had
to deal with because
i not only had them like all down the
back of my leg where they're
bulging and painful i have them
like in my vagina too sorry this is very
honest
it literally feels like somebody kicked
you in your crotch wow
so what is the reason for it like what's
the cause um
some they say it's hereditary um i had
i didn't have them my first pregnancy i
had them very slightly in my second
pregnancy and i was thinking like whoa
i've never noticed those before those
are crazy and then they immediately went
away after
but this time around they get worse with
every pregnancy they were
insane and i mean
it hurts it really really hurts and
there's not much you can do
so it looked painful yeah it was pretty
wild
um the one thing and i was like why did
they tell me this
and luckily i wasn't thinking about it
at all while giving birth but something
leading up to
birth was well hopefully when you're
pushing they don't pop
and i'm just thinking why would you tell
me that just keep that to yourself keep
that to yourself i don't want to hear
about things ruptured
no you're kidding so all i was thinking
was okay home birth
and i'm gonna push and my things gonna
explode
and so did your midwife have no problem
with that that was fine
no not at all yeah when i talked to my
midwife about it she was like we'll be
fine it's okay i have
stuff that you can just drink and take
and it's gonna help calm them down
um they still are pretty crazy they're
not as bad as they were before but
they're definitely
bruised and they clotted from all the
bed
bed rest at the hospital and we're
almost two months
oh like out from being in the hospital
and they're still
clotted wow it has gotten better though
much better
i mean i'm talking like balls like
rubber balls all throughout my life yeah
i mean the
human body the female human body
specifically on this topic is
absolutely amazing we're incredible what
we do we're incredible
so absolutely i mean like that we have
to realize and
and remind ourselves when we go through
all the things when we're growing a
human inside our body is that your body
is doing such a miraculous amazing thing
and we're not just growing a child we're
growing a world and a child
i mean there's a world in our tummy plus
a child inside
plus they're being fed all the time and
if you have other kids you're also
taking care of other kids
the things that we're capable of doing
it's really unreal it is unreal so when
we realize like the aches and the pains
and the
and the things we go through postpartum
even like we just did such an amazing
yeah for sure yeah i i don't think a lot
of people talk enough about
postpartum and healing after giving
birth because everything is so focused
on leading up to
birth and the birth itself that
postpartum i mean if you go through
like what you go through in childbirth
outside of that
like it would be equivalent to a car
accident and most people would tell you
to stay in bed and rest over
the next couple weeks and really like
how you can't do that as a mom when
they're like oh yeah get plenty of rest
how yeah i'm feeding my kid every two
hours
but somehow we like
like get this super natural strength and
energy to do it like sure i'm exhausted
but yet i'm functioning
really well and i don't know how that's
amazing yeah and i think
i want to do actually a whole probably
couple series episodes on postpartum and
healing
it's i think it's so important to like
have like a conversation about it
because so many i mean back when
my mom was giving birth like she didn't
i don't think have much conversation
around it and the importance and the
sacredness of healing
through what you just went through and
bonding with your baby so
yeah i mean just like having a community
being willing to voice your your needs
totally and letting other people take
care of you as much as possible is my
dog hard for me it's hard for chelsea
even our friend chelsea is like
yep she's just had her sixth baby and
she like gets up
she's like at target the week after she
gives birth i'm like what are you doing
girl
go home hold on that was me i was in
costco and and i'm literally holding rio
in like this little papoose thing
and um i had arrived from oahu
and i was at costco the very next day so
she's literally like a week
i'm one day old or like a week old or
something and
people are like how old is that baby
because she's you know she's only five
pounds at that time and i'm like oh
she's a week you're like
what are you doing walking around i know
i'm i'm not like that at all i'm really
i'm like i stay in bed for like four to
six weeks
where i like the only time i really get
out of bed is if like i need to go to
the bathroom or
like maybe by the third or fourth week
i'm like out in the front
like in the living room i do not do that
my fourth time
i found it so helpful like just letting
people take care of me like
and also like my husband is such a i'm
sure your husband is too and
obviously ryan chelsea's husband is too
but she's just you guys are just like i
got this
yes but also i don't know okay look i
believe that carlos would have it
yeah but he's so used to me being a
teammate right
that i think it would really throw him
off if i suddenly was like
i'm gonna take i'm gonna take a day off
even when i when i'm like baby i've got
it but you know what today i gotta go do
a couple meetings he's like oh well
how long are you gonna be going for
because i'm gonna hold down the floor
because i never have i never give him
that responsibility but this time around
like
there were three days where i've kind of
had to just be gone all day
and i'm like i'm not gonna take rio i'm
gonna leave her with you where he's
been forced to really be dad i mean he's
a fantastic dad and he takes the boys
all the time
but really giving him all three he's
kind of
put into this position where he does
have to figure it out because that's
what we do all the time
and i think often times moms without
realizing it we kind of take the father
role away
from them because we're like oh it's
okay we already know how to do it like
don't don't worry about it i've got it
and and we almost
we we look at them as like oh you're
helping me when it's like
no he's being a father like sure i can
say he's helping me but
he's doing his duties that's his role
absolutely i mean i even
um i was there for my sister's home
birth and like right after she gave
birth i was like about to leave i'm like
okay i'm gonna go back home like you
guys are good
and they're like wait what do we do and
like i totally did the same thing
because it's their first video
and i was like what you do is like you
stay in bed
all day and eric take care of her all
day
yeah do everything can you call carlos
yeah call carly i actually maybe i
should even do the postpartum episode
with my husband because he is like
please do like we have this whole system
where it's like literally
he makes all my food he brings it to me
he brings my water
he brings like my tinctures i need i
don't i don't get up okay carlos would
not know what to do with himself but
then again i wouldn't know what to do
with myself because i'm not
used to people helping me in that way
and some people it's easier to accept
help than others for sure
but i've learned and i've never
considered myself a prideful person
i don't think i'm prideful but it's
actually a symptom of pride
being like i can do it myself it's fine
and it's not that i don't think they can
like in my heart i don't want to put
somebody else out right and that's how
chelsea is too like such a giver that
it's really hard to receive it but it
comes from pride
right so the more and more i started
digging i was like it does come from
pride
no i don't want to be prideful um but
okay
two suggestions please do this with your
husband
like do that podcast with your husband
another thing that um
i would love maybe somebody to talk
about uh one day
is i have always felt like pregnancy has
been my loneliest time
because it's something that carlos will
never understand
and we're all we're such a team that
pregnancy
just pulls you kind of out of the normal
routine that you're in yeah like you get
really tired you're more fatigued you
can't you don't have the
same amount of energy that you had prior
to pregnancy
especially in the first and third yeah
like you don't know what morning
sickness is gonna do to you
and i really felt like you know we
fought
more during all of my pregnancies than
outside of this really
because he was just so i think and
carlos is amazing but i think he's so
used to me being a teammate that when
i'm not there he's frustrated and then
when he's not there for me because i'm
pregnant yeah i'm frustrated that
we decided we're like we have to do this
like 10 things i wish my husband knew
about pregnancy or like something so i'm
just so curious as to like
yeah like we should come back into
another episode about this yes i think
so because it's so good like pregnancy
has so many
things in itself for sure and everyone's
pregnancy experience is different it's
really different and from kid to kid
it's
different oh from kid to kid totally for
us it's definitely like the post
postpartum phase is harder because like
in relationship wise rather than
pregnancy like i have felt really good
throughout my pregnancies
and the postpartum phase i'm like you
know we know like you need to heal
because really you will
stop bleeding sooner if you don't if you
can rest i know you rest
and just let the thing is though not
everybody has that option to let
have people take care of them like they
have multiple kids or they're a single
parent and
in that i just say like literally just
do the best that you can in reaching out
to anybody that you feel safe with
to ask for help and not be afraid to ask
for help and things like meal training
and we'll do a whole episode i know
that was my first experience with meal
train this last pregnancy i've never had
anybody cook for us like
we've really limited it though we're
like okay those three people and that's
it cut it off
okay you and chelsea must be the same
person because chelsea did the same
thing and i'm like just let all of us
we love you chelsea chelsea you're the
best you're the best
and then our friend yachty is like
similar to me where she's like i'm
like hibernating for six weeks you won't
see me for six weeks i'm like in advice
i think it's like
for you guys i'll get there you will
we'll get there
you'll totally we'll watch the podcast
both me and carlos we'll watch a
podcast and you know there's so much to
say about it but what i was gonna say i
forgot was that
it's harder for us because um acts of
service is andrew's love language where
he not only gives that best but he also
like loves that the best and like i
can't do that in the first like
beginning phase i
i won't and we know that mindset going
in and that's why he's like so on it
because he knows like
i can hear you yeah and i and he wants
to do it because it comes naturally to
him but over time
it is harder because like i'm bonding
with the baby and i'm like
i'll get to you later you know and so it
like then
right it can be tough at the beginning
it's definitely hard because everything
is on your baby and if you have multiple
kids as well
it's a lot you're very you're spread out
but
what was cool was this time i mean we've
never had
help with like any of our kids during
like the childbirth thing
through any of it um other than when
we're on set and
this time around we were like man it
would be so nice to have like parents on
island or grandparents or somebody here
to just kind of
give us those moments but what was
awesome was
we had to figure it out with three kids
and
it really kind of set the tone for the
family
that we were like creating it wasn't
just this we didn't allow it to get too
chaotic and crazy and we didn't allow
ourselves to feel overwhelmed we were
like you know what
this is just our situation we don't have
outside help we don't have family here
and we're gonna figure it out on our own
and we did and we felt like our kids
were better for it we were better for it
and now we kind of feel like
superhumans right like we could do
anything we can have five more kids
totally and i can imagine like talking
about this main topic of the
episode about like healing from trauma
and birth and not getting the birth you
plan that
your postpartum could be harder if you
were really struggling with the outcome
that you had
right and i i feel like i'm not really
sure like where
how do you help the the most in that
like post-program i mean you have such a
positive alex so we know that
but like someone who is struggling where
do we go from there when you're like
healing from birth physically but also
mentally
let's see um oh gosh i feel like i'm i'm
just keep repeating myself but it goes
back to like
really counting your wins counting your
blessings and seeing what you do have
um because again like even when my kids
are
acting crazy i just always go back to
like when my kids are wild and silly
um they can be driving me nuts but then
five minutes later
they're doing something so precious or
coming over to me asking me if i need a
hug
and like those little things are just so
life-giving
so really focus on the things that are
life-giving and sometimes that's just
music for some people like
i can't tell you how music changes my
mood
i so often like i use my car time
because that's when usually i'm alone
as my prayer time so i'm usually praying
and meditating in the car and it's super
good for me because how often do we have
silence when we're in like a crazy busy
household
um but then you know after i'm done
praying i'm like all right i just need
some good tunes and i put music on and i
find myself just
being like filled with life so like put
some good tunes on
diffuse some nice oils um put on like
take a bath or take a nice warm
shower i just feel like do the things
that bring you life yes
and also and also like asking for help
yes if you're not that's still hard for
me i'm really learning that
so i have not implemented that yet so
asking for help doing things that ring
joy and also
surrounding yourself with women that
have possibly gone through a trauma
as well that you can share your
experiences with so i did that online
that's why because i wasn't able to i
didn't know any other women
um um that had gone through trauma let
alone like i'm still finding women here
on
island like i'm just getting to know you
there's like so many new things are
opening up for me but
if you don't have access to necessarily
like
even friends like if you don't have
friends who understand what you're going
through
or anybody who gets it go online and
just start reading
like other people's stories and their
testimonies of how they got through it
because i knew
nothing about the nicu prior to going in
and then my nicu experience i'm like
okay i have to look this up so i know
like
what do i like what are the milestones
how have other people gone through this
like what do other moms think
and reading their stories reading
husbands stories it
helped me so much it just kind of gave
me like
oh we've got this like they look at what
they did look at how they implemented
things and
and really wanting to also like i just
bought all this stuff for like the
nurses in the nicu but then finding
things i'm like i have to donate to the
nicu now now i'm so passionate about the
nicu because
they really like they save your babies
they're amazing
amazing yeah amazing um i also think oh
shoot what was i gonna say i was gonna
mention something about
sorry i'm all over the place i go off on
a lot of tangents oh i'm a tangent queen
i love it we've had such a good
conversation i forget what i was gonna
say
i'm sorry no i had a thing oh about
oh i know what i was gonna say okay in
my second birth i think that there's a
lot of like you know when we hear the
stories of other people
and we think birth is supposed to go a
certain way so like my first one
was super long it was like 26 hours long
um just like from start to finish right
and i was so
proud of myself like that my goal was
just have a home birth and like
that was my goal and i had that and it
was amazing i'm so proud of you for
doing a home birth after labor for 24
hours oh my gosh
in the moment i was so mad i was like
why is this taking so long yup actually
did the
hypno babies thing no way i had done the
hypno babies class with
um three other women and i remember in
the middle of my labor i was like this
hypno
baby thing is [ __ ] it's crap like it
doesn't
work i was so mad i'm like it doesn't
work at all it's
horrible but then in the end i was like
oh my gosh it's amazing
but that was crap it didn't work and i
remember thinking like it didn't work
for me right
and that was and then i talked to the
other women and like two out of the four
women
said they experienced like a pain-free
birth and i was like how i don't get it
for me so then the sec because it's like
we have this story it's like i'm gonna
do the hypno
birthing and it's gonna make me have
like a you know less pain in my breath
we have to remember every body is
physically different in your mind like
a true believer in the power of the mind
that's why i think the mindset thing
like drew me so much to you
because i had i've had personal
experiences within mind change myself
which i've talked about on my youtube
channel but i'm sure i'll talk about it
more like here on the podcast
but then in my second birth i was told
over and over again it's gonna go so
much faster
second birth is always faster second
worth is always so so much faster and
then i had a friend who had just had
her second baby and it was like in and
out of the hospital in four hours and it
was
or not out but like yeah but like down
there baby's born in six in four to six
hours and i was like yeah that's gonna
be me
second home birth now my goal is not
only have a home birth but like a short
birth
that was my goal i did not get that the
birth was
literally the same length it was like 24
hours oh my gosh i was
so mad i'm like this is not how it was
supposed to go
and i just felt disappointed in myself
but you know everyone has their own
different versions of like what they
were
well because we think we can control it
yeah and we can't yeah we can't we have
zero control over right
situations and i think i always tell
people
especially after this i'm like have a
plan that's fantastic
but know that you have zero control on
the outcome and if the plan goes
like just as you would hope that's
awesome good for you like that's so rad
but if if it doesn't and most likely it
won't not to be a negative nancy like i
again
i always say you use it in a positive
way but i'm using in a positive way like
who cares if it doesn't go the way i
wanted it it means that it's gonna go
better
so even though it might not look like it
was a better situation to have to be in
the nicu
that was the safest and best option for
my baby
i would much rather have delivered and
had her go to the nicu
than to have delivered it home and her
needed all of these things that we
didn't have access to
totally so for me i was like great like
god god is in control like
we had that experience and that was
perfect that's the impact that you're
having by sharing your story because
other women who have had maybe similar
experiences or in the future may have an
experience like that
can look back on that be like i have a
choice to have this type of mindset
you know because then after i had my
second long one two being able to speak
to other women whether they had shorter
ones or longer ones like helped me
relate to like
okay we're all different yeah you know
and then the third one's where i really
had my true
mind change i don't know if you watched
my you said you watched some of my
videos but i did like a video on like my
birth story with scout
i didn't watch that and so i had a
neighbor at the time
who had done this thing called mind
change okay i'm gonna have her on the
podcast yeah
i i think you will love it it is her the
concept of what she does in vain she
helps you
rewire your brain because the power of
mind is so positive like so important
powerful that you can shift what happens
within
your mind and what happens in reality
yep and i had the most amazing birth
like my birth
no way next level just by doing this one
session with her and her husband
like three days before i went into labor
i was like i don't know this is gonna
work and they're like well
even if you don't think it's gonna work
it'll still work like it's that powerful
and i was like all right
like i was just very skeptical okay
crazy people
i had literally just done like the hypno
babies the first one i was like that
definitely didn't work for me and
they're like well no this is this is
different
it was like an hour and a half thing
like sure literally my birth was exactly
how
they were like what's your ideal birth
it was eight hours long which was like a
huge win for me yeah i felt i almost
felt like a failure
it's even though i loved my birth and i
was i feel so positive
and like powerful about my first two
home births like i love them and there's
nothing i would change about them
now but in the moment i was like looking
at it like why couldn't they do it
because you hear about other stories and
we're in this
like our whole world is about comparison
right
totally and we get so caught up in
comparison and there's no need because
like we said like
everybody is physically different every
mind is different and
you know you can be the most positive
person or the most negative person but
at the end of the day like
you can't control when a baby is gonna
come out and how long it's going to take
them
absolutely and but you can change your
mind you can change your mind and then
also like hearing other people's stories
is helpful to realize because there's so
there's so many ways things happen so
then i eventually being like it's okay
that it happened that way
but the fact that i almost like felt
like i couldn't have a short birth
like my mind was like i wouldn't be able
to have a short birth because you know
you have your friends who are like i
just walked in the shower and i looked
down at my baby
coming out and i'm like what
i would just be like oh i wasn't
prepared like if that happens
my friend joseph had the most incredible
like birth where it was like literally
like an hour and a half long i'm not
sure if i would even want to birth that
short but like just seeing it on
on camera where she's like oh go send
her son nico to the neighbors and then
he comes back and she's like the baby's
coming out get the phone and so he's
like beating it right his baby's coming
out in the shower like so
fast all i'm thinking and i'm sorry this
is like tmi but i'm just thinking
that she has to go from like not dilated
to like
fully dilated in a very short amount of
time
and what does that feel like what does
your body do
like you get the shakes i even felt the
shakes like after the eight
hour one you know but she like she
pulled the baby up it's like the most
amazing video she pulled it up and she
was like
that was amazing that that didn't even
hurt she's like
she's like thank you hypno baby so she
had done the hypno oh it worked for her
my gosh maybe i tried that i don't know
i don't know
or the mind change thing i'll do them
all or both that's the one
thing i never prepared for any of my
births i never took classes i never did
anything
and i'm one of seven kids and i was
there for a lot of my siblings births
births so i just assume like yeah great
i've got this so
i'm literally in the middle of having my
first kid and i realized i don't know
how to breathe and i'm just like
i'm like running out they have to put me
on oxygen i feel like i'm gonna vomit
like
all this stuff and they're like okay you
didn't do any classes did you and i was
like no
so they're like all right sweetie it's
okay just like do a deep breath and then
i'm like going through like some pushing
and then the nurse goes and what they
say about the ring of fire is true but
it's okay
and i'm just like you're like that's so
funny because my first two i didn't
experience the ring of fire
i felt like my labor was so intense that
once i got to the pushing it felt like
just a huge release really like i was
like i'm past that and then the third
one
even though i had that like everything i
focused on in the mind change
didn't come down to the pushing because
my first two was so easy pushing
i didn't think about it that when i came
to this one the labor was like
incredibly short and amazing
then when i got to the pushing i was
like
i didn't i didn't work on this part in
the mind i did not work on that
but it ended up all that to say it was
like my i had such a powerful
transformative experience by changing my
mind through the mind change stuff
but just showing how every birth is
different and how
and how you might have these like
feelings that of failure and what
in your own terms that to someone else
would be like a total victory
right and so that's my mindset is so
mindset is huge
again i feel like you can't control the
situation or the outcome
always but it's amazing what having a
positive mind will do
because it'll take what somebody saw as
such a negative and turn it into a
such a positive that in a way it does
change the circumstance like
you then do kind of control the
situation even though i feel like
it gosh i know that doesn't make sense
but no it does
you can't control a situation but when
you know that you can't control a
situation it suddenly feels like you are
in control because
you're like well whatever happens
happens i'm gonna be happy regardless
absolutely and then i feel in control
like instead of the what ifs and the
what the unknowns
right and the story of birth i think is
really impactful to us in our psyche and
the way that we're taught like what
birth is supposed to be like or whatever
earth is going to be like
um but do you have i mean kind of like
coming closer to a
closing closer to a close do you have
anything that like you'd like to share
that you've experienced maybe not
related to birth or pregnancy that was
like
something you didn't expect or something
you didn't plan or didn't go the way you
wanted it and how you responded to that
like outside of birth
so many things there i can't i mean i
can't even count how many times things
have not
gone the way that i wanted but i'll just
give one really easy example
um i was up for those of you that know
like i i'm an actress
um i was up for this show called the
mentalist
no no it was a different show
um i was up for um
and now i can't remember the name of the
show oh it was a big show and it shot
uh like in georgia or somewhere over
there um and i was up for this show and
i was so
excited i was so excited to like
hopefully get this role
and i didn't get it and i was so bummed
and i'm just thinking you know what
this sucks like i worked so hard for
this i like
i worked my butt off all this stuff
i get a call two months later and
they're like hey
we want you to come do the show but you
know it's not the part that you wanted
and it's like not a series regular we
just want you to guest star on it
and i was like you know what yeah that
sounds like a great idea i'm gonna go i
go
i have the worst experience ever really
like
normally the crew is like my favorite
right the crew like
hated life for whatever reason i don't
know if they just had a really hard time
on the show
but like the ads which normally i get
along with so well were just
mean and grumpy and really treated me
like crap oh man
all i was thinking was oh my gosh this
is why i didn't get the show
because it would have been like this day
in and day out and it would have sucked
the life out of me
so all all that being said is i was
so bummed that i didn't get an
opportunity with that show and i
remember praying being like god why
i worked so hard and i wanted it and
then when i had that it was like he gave
me a glimpse of what it would have been
like
and that gave me that closure of you
always have my back and i'm not gonna
question when something doesn't go the
way that i want it to go
because you know what i need not
not what i am like hoping for and that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't hope we
should always hope we should always be
like excited about you know goals and
and and wants and i always feel like
it's important to like put your wants
out there
but if it doesn't go the way that you
want it to just know it's for a good
reason
yeah like sometimes it feels almost like
maybe not naive but like a a disc if
someone goes through something like
super
super traumatic like a loss like that so
like it's hard to navigate through that
conversation of like everything happens
for a reason but really
truly so many people even experiencing
so many traumas that
when you go through something that's so
intense whether it's a loss or
not the pregnancy you planned or some
other kind of hard experience that is
not how your
ideal plan was in life looking back
later you learn
so much from that situation and often
you find
beauty and almost like thankfulness that
maybe you wouldn't have experienced
later on like if you didn't experience
right so like someone who
had had their first birth not go the way
that they planned i almost felt like
that was ripped from them in some form
of way
but then when they have their second
birth and have like a totally healing
regenerative
birth that's transformative they might
have not
appreciated it as much as they did
if they didn't experience it the first
time and i've found that so much in my
life that
by experiencing something hard in the
moment it's so hard but then when i
later look back and go that had to
happen or i would not have had this
gratitude that you have
ultimate unapologetic uh unapologetic
gratitude yes and and i think we all
need that it's a really humbling
thing but i always tell god i'm like
please don't humble me
like i'm gonna humble myself don't worry
like please don't take everything away
yeah you don't want to have to you don't
want to have to be humbled but
i again i always look back at the things
that were most transforming in my life
and it was always those hard times
that really i go wow like i wish i
didn't experience that
but having experienced that has
completely changed
the way i live now and for the better
totally
so we have i think our wins i think that
is a beautiful way to end this show i
love it so glad we had this conversation
it's easy we could do this forever i
know we should just just just just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just very tight
sorry no you're kidding me i'm so
thankful you shared your story i think
it's an amazing one
super impactful and i appreciate so much
everything that you said
i like i totally resonate with and i man
this was just such a great show
thank you so much for being on the show
and listen whenever you want me back
um we're doing that yes let's end it
here and then
go back to carlos and he cannot i will
save him i will save him he's done well
he has three kids he's doing well
angel's got the four over there it's
okay they'll hang out then
they'll have the seven and they've got
it right great okay let's end it bye
guys bye
you